esta vez tenemos la función g por aquí y
lo que quiero que hagas es para usar el
video y que averigües cuánto vale g de 1
g de 1 g de 2 g de 2g 3g de 3 y de 4 g
de 4 así que es momento de que pausas el
vídeo y los resuelvas por ti mismo
ok ahora trabajemos esto juntos queremos
que de uno estás de acuerdo
veamos si n es igual a 1 bueno pues que
va a valer 4 justo estamos en este caso
en donde n es igual a 1 y si en es igual
a 1
entonces g de uno va a valer 4 esto
estuvo muy fácil ahora veamos que de 2g
de 2 bueno si n vale 2
entonces date cuenta que caemos en este
caso 2 es más grande que uno y es un
número natural es decir un número entero
positivo por lo tanto vamos a usar este
caso que es mucho más interesante porque
date cuenta que la función no está
definida en términos de n en este caso
estamos definiendo la función en
términos de g dn menos uno
así que si n baleados entonces tenemos
que evaluar g de dos y para evaluar g de
todos nos quedaría g de dos menos uno lo
cual es g de uno aquí me quedaría
de 13.2 más 3.2 y cuánto será esto bueno
pues que de uno ya lo sabemos que de uno
es igual a cuatro lo acabamos de
descubrir aquí arriba recuerdas y bueno
43.2 es lo mismo que 7.2 perfecto es
hora de seguir con ge de tres y que de
tres a cuánto va a ser igual
bien pues note que regresamos a este
caso de nuevo porque 3 es más grande que
1 y 13 es un número natural por lo tanto
que de 3 va a ser igual a g de 3 menos
uno que es g de 292 más 3.2 más 3.2 pero
date cuenta que g de dos ya lo sabemos
lo tenemos justo acá arriba recuerdas
que de 27.2 y bueno 7.2 más 3.2 es lo
mismo que 10.4
así que vayamos a g de 4 y bueno
volvemos a caer en este caso así kg de 4
va a ser lo mismo que g de 3 kg de 3 +
3.2 más 3.2 pero que de 3 lo averiguamos
acá arriba era lo mismo que 10.4 por lo
tanto 10.4 más 3.2 es 13.6 y bueno al
tate cuenta que esto es bastante
interesante porque puedes pensar esta
función g como una función definida en
todos los enteros positivos y porque
está definida en todos los sentidos
positivos bueno porque estamos
definiendo una sucesión y aquí podemos
ver la sucesión es la siguiente la
sucesión bueno si te das cuenta su
primer término es 4 así que lo voy a
poner aquí 4
su siguiente término sería 7.27 punto 2
después sigue 10.4 10.4 su tercer
término después 13.6 el cuarto término
es 3.6 y así te puede seguir mantener
y manteniendo y manteniendo sacando más
términos de esta sucesión ahora bien lo
que quiero que notes es qué está pasando
con esta sucesión
bueno pues empezamos con un valor de 4
que es justo lo que tenemos aquí cuando
n vale 1 g de 1 vale 4 y entonces
nuestra función toma este valor y ahora
por cada término después de éste tomamos
el término previo y le vamos a sumar 3.2
por lo tanto de aquí para acá lo que
hicimos fue agregar 3.2 de aquí para acá
lo que hicimos fue agregar 3.2 de aquí
para acá también agregamos 3.2 3.2 y así
nos podemos mantener sumando 3.2 de
hecho ahora podemos definirlo de esta
manera porque tenemos un primer término
que es 4 y agregamos 3.2 para encontrar
cada siguiente término y esta es una
forma muy interesante de definir esta
función es una forma de definirla porque
es un
funcional hebraica es decir una función
que está definida sobre todos los entre
los positivos y en donde tenemos un caso
base el cual nos da el primer término
justo esto de aquí y después tenemos los
otros casos que van a estar definidos en
términos de la función que tú vas a
tener en una recursión hacia atrás que
eventualmente va a hacer que regreses al
caso base y por eso llamamos a esta
función una función recursiva así que
déjame escribirlo por acá arriba esta es
una función función
recursiva
si va y de hecho justo en este ejemplo
podemos ver como nuestra función
recursiva nos ayuda a definir nuestra
sucesión actual y bueno podemos ir en
esta dirección pero también podemos ir
en dirección contraria podríamos decir
no sea averiguar cuánto es el valor de g
de 6 se me ocurra 76 y bueno si queremos
saber el valor de g de 6 entonces esto
es lo mismo por la función que gt5 más
3.2 estás de acuerdo
de 5
3.2
cuánto vale g de 5 bueno pues que de 5
usando la definición de la función es lo
mismo que ge ge de 43.2 estás de acuerdo
más 3.2 y así podremos seguir
retrocediendo y retrocediendo y
retrocediendo pero pues ya sabemos
cuánto me aleje de 4 así que vamos a
usarlo en esta ocasión gt4 es 13.6 13.6
ahora 13.6 + 3.2 es 16.8 de lujo g de
56.8 así que vamos a usarlo para obtener
g de 676 va a ser 16.8 + 3.2 lo cual es
20 de lujo así que podríamos empezar con
g de 6 él nos regresa bando y regresando
y regresando y regresando hasta llegar
al punto en que tengamos a que de 1 es
decir a nuestro caso base el cual
sabemos su valor y con él seremos
capaces de llenar todos los demás
espacios vacíos bien ahora veamos un par
de ejemplos más sobre este mismo tema
voy a bajar la pantalla y vamos
con este de aquí tenemos esta función de
aquí y digamos que esta función define
una sucesión
así que pongamos los cuatro primeros
términos de esta sucesión y te encargo
que pausa el vídeo e intente resolverlo
por ti mismo
ok manos a la obra tengo que h de 1h de
1 quien va a ser bueno eso es muy
sencillo porque nos dan justo aquí si n
vale 1 hd uno va a ser 14 así que h de
uno toma el valor de 14 de lujo ahora
pensemos en hd 2
bueno pues hd2 va a hacer pues date
cuenta que ahora entramos en este caso
porque 2 es más grande que 1 y 2 es un
número natural entonces nos quedarán que
hd2 va a ser igual a 28 entre h de 1
entre h de 1 pero sabemos cuánto vale h
de 1h de unos 14 por lo tanto me va a
quedar 28 entre 14
y esto me va a dar de respuesta 2 de
lujo ahora pensemos en hd 3 h de 3 bueno
esto va a ser lo mismo que date cuenta
que volvemos a caer en este caso porque
3 más grande que uno y es un número
natural entonces me quedaría 28 28 entre
hd 2 entre el hd2 pero nosotros ya
sabemos cuánto vale hd 2 hd 2 es 2 por
lo tanto me va a quedar 28 entre 2 y
esto es lo mismo que 14 es decir que
esta sucesión es bastante interesante
donde el término previo está dividiendo
al número 28 así que tenemos que 28
entre 12 14 y algo muy interesante está
pasando por aquí y creo que tú empiezas
a ver cuánto va a ser hd4 bueno pues hd
4 es lo mismo que me recuerda que hemos
de nuevo en este caso me va a quedar 28
28 entre h de 3 pero nosotros ya sabemos
cuánto vale hd3 esto me va
28 entre 14 recuérdalo este de aquí es h
3 no lo olvides
y entonces regresamos de nuevo al 2
ahora observa lo que está pasando porque
si pensamos esto como una sucesión me va
a quedar lo siguiente tengo que el
primer término es 14 después tengo el
segundo término el cual es 2 el tercer
término va a ser 14 el cuarto término va
a ser 2 y bueno así se mantiene y lo que
quiero que veas es que esta sucesión es
una sucesión de términos que se van
alternando entre el 14 y el 2 14 2 14 2
todos los términos impares de esta
sucesión serán 14 y los pares serán 2
bueno esa es otra forma de pensarlo y la
otra forma de pensarlo es que empezamos
en 14 y después cada término sucesivo es
28 dividido por el término premium es
decir que tenemos 28 entre 14 lo cual me
va a dar 2 y después vamos a tener 28
entre 2 lo cual me va a dar 14 28 entre
28 22 14 y seguimos seguimos seguimos
esto es justo lo que no está diciendo
esta parte de aquí muy bien así que
vayamos a hacer otro ejercicio más para
terminar este vídeo déjenme bajar un
poco la pantalla y ahora vamos a
trabajar con este ejercicio de aquí en
el cual date cuenta que nos dan dos
casos bases así que pensemos lo un poco
no sé se me ocurre que queremos esta vez
averiguar el valor de f de 4 de f de 4
muy bien date cuenta que cuando el nivel
de 4 caemos en este caso en es más
grande que 2 y en es un número natural y
por lo tanto bueno nos va a quedar que f
de 4 es lo mismo que efe de n 1 lo cual
me va a quedar
efe de 4 menos uno que es f de 3 más
efe dn 24 - 22 entonces también quiero a
efe de dos ahora sería muy bueno
averiguar cuánto vale f de 3 así que
vamos a hacerlo
efe de 3 y observa que de nuevo que
hemos en este caso 32 y
número natural y por lo tanto me va a
quedar que efe de 3 es lo mismo que f de
3 - 1 lo cual es de 2 más
efe de 3 - 2 lo cual es efe
de 1
ahora si queremos saber cuánto vale
entre 2
bueno pues ten cuidado porque ahora
caemos en este caso base en esta ocasión
tenemos dos casos bases y si n vale 2
entonces
efe de 2 toma el valor de menos 4 por lo
tanto efe de 2 es igual a menos 4 muy
bien y si queremos el valor de f1
bueno pues también caemos en un caso
base estamos justo aquí si n vale 1 f1
es menos 6 y entonces lo voy a poner
aquí menos 6 del lujo en esta ocasión
tenemos dos casos base y es importante
que los notes aquí estos son nuestros
casos casos base base y estos casos base
están definidos en términos de la
función y los necesitas porque de otra
forma tú estarías en la reclusión hacia
atrás para siempre y nunca obtendrías
estos números tangibles así que son muy
importantes los casos base y vamos a
utilizarlos porque si queremos definir
esta sucesión entonces lo que voy a
obtener es lo siguiente -
6 este st de 1 después me va a quedar
menos 4 este es f 2 y después me va a
quedar
efe de tres pero efe de tres está
detenido como jefe de dos más efe de uno
lo cual va a ser menos 6 menos 4 y esto
es menos 10
efe de 3 es menos 10 y después
efe de 4 está detenido como la suma de
los dos anteriores es decir
efe de 3 más efe de 2 y el que me
quedarían menos 10 menos 4 lo cual es
menos 14 entonces aquí tengo menos 14 y
así podemos seguir y seguir y seguir
seguir lo importante de este vídeo y de
hecho el punto al que yo quería llegar
es lo siguiente quiero que notes que las
funciones recursivas pueden definir
sucesiones y además quería que te
familiarizarás con estas funciones
recursivas